Dale jr. NASCAR on NBC analyst
semi-retired NASCAR driver he was
elected to the NASCAR Hall of Fame
yesterday part of the class of 2021 and
he just finished fifth and the Hooters
250 at Homestead this past weekend
junior joining us congratulations
are you semi-retired what is your
driving status here Dale I think it's
retired but because when I race once a
year it's in the Xfinity series which is
kind of like our minor leagues I get to
go down in that series it's a much
shorter race than the cup race on Sunday
but half the distance and I get to race
against the guys that may be racing for
Cup championships in five to ten 15
years so I enjoy it I get a little
chance to remind myself a lot about what
being in the race cars like so if I'm in
the broadcast booth over the over the
period of being in a broadcast booth for
a year two years three years you you you
forget you forget what that heat and
that stress is all about what goes
through a drivers mind and so it really
keeps all that refreshed on my memory so
that when I'm in the booth I can talk a
little a little bit more about what the
drivers are going through with
confidence so I'm gonna try to do that
one race a year as long as as long as I
can I guess but you know for that very
reason alone because I feel like it
makes me so much better and the booth
gives me a lot more confidence in the
booth to be able to talk about what I
think of drivers what I think is going
through drivers mind
what is that helmet over your left
shoulder on the desk there's a 1974
Winston Racing Series championship
helmet that was given to a guy named
Jimmy means me and when I was a little
boy I went to the racetrack and I'm a
huge underdog fan I love an underdog
story Jimmy was a independent that ran
toward the back of the pack on borrowed
equipment and he was parked next to my
father in the garage at North Wilkesboro
Speedway probably around 1985-86 and
there and I said you know I think I'm
gonna pull for this
dad and he goes you want to meet him and
so he took me right over to meet Jimmy
Jimmy's working on his car and had a few
volunteers helping him at the racetrack
me and Jimmy's son Brad are the same age
and from that moment on me and Brad
became great friends and would seek each
other out at the races on the weekends
to hang out Brad gave me that helmet
because that was awarded to his father
back in 1974 for racing he was a very
successful short track racer in Alabama
Nashville and before he moved on to the
Cup Series that's pretty cool what's the
best piece of it are you at home now or
is that work okay what's the coolest
piece of memorabilia you got there I
this is a great story and I'm surprised
if I hadn't told you this but I was
cleaning out an attic on a building and
I had been just throwing junk up there
old monitors and all kinds of things
that were that I just don't throw stuff
away probably hoard too much stuff keep
too much crap but so I'm looking through
this attic and we're cleaning it out we
got a flatbed pickup truck that we're
throwing all this garbage and old stuff
onto I found a black trash bag and I
just chunked it into the back of this
truck with a bunch of other stuff
thank thankfully a friend of mine was
that was down in that truck bed looked
in that bag and he goes hey there's a
driver's uniform in this bag and I was
like oh man I don't want to throw that
away I thinking it was probably one of
mine he pulls it out and it's a yellow
uniform with blue stripes on the sleeves
the Wrangler way before that so I get
this uniform and I start looking at it
and after about a month or two of
looking at pictures and comparing the
patches the location of the patches and
all the things any kind of
identification to the to the uniform
this uniform is the 1979 uniform my dad
used when he won his first Cup race at
the Bristol Tennessee I don't know how I
got it I don't know why it was in a
black trash bag
and I almost threw it away oh my I mean
that that load was going straight to the
dump never to be seen again so I think
because of that experience as traumatic
as it was I'm so glad that I had that I
also have a uniform of my grandfather
Ralph Earnhardt that I just acquired
recently and I have those two together
and that's just that stuff you can't
really put a price on it's one-of-a-kind
and you know it's close to my family
do you ever did you think about creating
your own Museum we have you know at
Junior Motorsports over tire shop it's
about 10 minutes from my house we ran a
four car race team and we've always
talked about if we ever did downsize or
if Junior Motorsports wasn't in racing
every single weekend that we could use
that space and we have I think we have
enough stuff that would be interesting
of people to want to come through there
we'd get a lot of foot traffic into our
in our shop we give tours throughout the
week and so you know we still have
pretty good foot traffic I was wondering
you know when I retired if that would
just kind of died down and people might
not be interested in coming to our place
anymore maybe going to more current race
teams and seeing what's going on with
teams that are competing today but the
foot traffic's been pretty good so yeah
I mean we've thought about that and I
have quite a quite a unique collection
of stuff old autographs and things like
that that I've acquired over the years
he's a Dale junior going into the Hall
of Fame how does that sound
I hadn't sunk in yet it's weird that
means you're old I think Junior well I I
think you know I was in my opinion I'm
I'm much too young to go into the Hall
of Fame and if you really looked at the
sheet of nominees man I'm so much
younger than a lot of those guys and so
I was really totally comfortable with
waiting for my turn because a lot of
those guys man they everyone on that
sheet belongs in there and they will get
in there one day I think it's automatic
if you even get nominated that you're
going into the Hall at some point even
with the restrictions that they have but
I was just blown away to be selected
above guy
like Harry Gant Neil Bonnett and others
that that truly belong in that Hall of
Fame so I as I am to be a part of it I'm
looking forward to the future inductees
as we go down the road and standing on
stage with those guys I'm getting text
messages from all my friends all of all
the guys in the sport in the industry
even Hall of Famers themselves Ray
Evernham Mark Martin Roger Penske and I
told him I said I can't wait to stand on
that stage next to you guys that's just
going to be an emotional experience but
I'm I was really proud to be selected
how much the family Amy's great she's a
midway through her pregnancy with our
second child we're gonna have a little
girl in October I was 26 27 months
starting to ask why which is kind of
cool you know all the things that people
tell you that you know kind of might get
a little old or get terrible twos that
they talk about and all that stuff when
she starts doing anything new I get
excited
she's she's getting hard-headed she's
getting we're sort of getting him we're
really transitioning into that phase
where we're starting to have to
understand of decide how we want to
discipline her and she's starting to get
to the point where she she needs to
understand not to do this and that the
other instead of us telling when we tell
her hey don't do that don't grab that
don't pick that up she does it cuz you
think it's funny or thinks it's a game
and we need to sort of figure out how to
parenting stuff man we need to figure
out how to help her understand you know
what the rules are and when we mean
business
you need you need a crew chief she may
take after her grandfather yeah I have
you know I don't know exactly the the
right way to do it but we're learning on
the fly try to you'll never figure it
out jr. it's survival to the next day
and I have three girls to go along with
my son they're gonna be days when you're
gonna look at Amy and go I don't and
you're gonna be you're already
outnumbered you're gonna go I don't I
have no
what's going on here because the range
of emotions that those girls are gonna
have you're gonna go help me here I have
no idea what's going on I know and I'm
all right I'm all right I've always you
know Amy Amy came Amy coming to my life
and gave me so much love and iowa has
done the same thing I'm anticipating our
next delivery to to add even more love
their home and so I am in I'm in heaven
with all these girls around me I want to
: hold on to me oh absolutely yeah girls
never leave you to that's that's the
beauty the girls funny I was you know me
where I was walking down the street and
I had eyelet in a stroller and I'm
pushing I walked by this guy and he
turns around and goes she's gonna break
your heart about sixteen years I thought
man I hope that's not true she will she
will absolutely hey before I let you go
Bubba Wallace who stands here with the
Confederate flag man I I mean that's a
gutsy move to do it and what he's been
doing I don't know if you've had a
chance to talk to him about this he's
been very very busy but I was very proud
of him and I it's a long time coming you
know and we we've we've had
conversations about that in our sport
over the last two decades and I'm so
proud of not you obviously Bubba
but our sport standing behind him our
leaders in our sport standing behind him
and making for change and and and you
know I know that's the gonna be a
difficult road for them and for us going
forward
but this was monumental Bubba said it
NASCAR reacted that was incredible I
couldn't I didn't even know you could
you could do that I know you could ban a
flag so you know kudos to NASCAR for for
their efforts to support Bubba and all
the sport you know we just want
everybody to feel comfortable when they
come to the racetrack and it sucks that
there's anybody that feels like they
can't come to the racetrack because they
don't feel wanted
don't feel comfortable can't enjoy the
experience and that's not
that's not what we're looking for we're
looking for everybody to be able to come
and watch the races and and have a great
time have a great family atmosphere my
best to Amy and hope everything goes
well with the delivery and going into
the Hall of Fame and uh it's good to
talk to you hey buddy
always good to talk to you guys Thank
You Junior that's a Dale Earnhardt jr.